the fourth game of the World
Championship Match in Chennai was a
fascinating fight Magnus Carlson
defended against fishi Anan 1 E4 with a
Berlin ending and after some early
inaccuracies by the world champion it
was the Challenger who gained the upper
hand however Anan defended extremely
well and managed to reach a drawn double
Rook ending even there Carlson found
some ways to make life difficult for the
opponent but Anan did not lose the
threat and Sav the draw something went
horribly wrong in the opening I mean I I
made one illogical move after the next
and
then I just missed something uh with
92 and
suddenly uh I'm yeah I'm just basically
lost towards the end it was a bit scary
in this four Rook end
game but um finally when I give a check
on A8 and get to G8 then
I'm I'm safe well of course I'm very
happy with um the way
opening went um I mean I was feeling
pretty good early on uh and then of
course when when I won the
pawn
uh I was very optimistic
but uh he he kept finding
resources uh I was missing some little
things
and uh I mean he just fought on really
well and
uh uh today I couldn't couldn't do do
enough to to break him now
so um it's a bit of a Pity to have
spoiled such a good position but it was
a very good fight so I cannot be
too unhappy let's go right to our
interview with Gary Gasparov who visited
the match during games three and four
definitely both players try hard to make
sure that you know both the the two
games while I was here they're very
exciting a lot of fun and uh that's you
know that's what we expect from the
world championship so it's
um Fighting Chess ideas uh determination
to play to the very end so uh and um I
I'm
also thly impressed by by the enthusiasm
of the crowd here so and by the interest
of the match both on the sport and
around the world so I I think that this
match you
uh proves again that classic chess is
not dead so there's still a lot of
excitement and the world championship
match itself uh represents unique value
that uh must be protected so 10 years of
the noout tournament I think that was
the uh um disastrous experiment uh um
was more than enough even for FID to to
to to recognize uh for ill F to
recognize that uh world championship
match is is uh something that cannot be
touched uh and uh experimented with uh
not by accident that we have few real
you
know few Champions over
100 25 years of the history of the world
championship matches and uh uh there are
15 and um okay there's a chance that the
the new the new name will be will emerge
and uh be added to this to this list um
after Chennai but uh whatever is the
outcome of the match I think it uh it um
I think secures the um um the image of
the match uh for general public and uh
also I believe with uh the match and the
interest for the match and the
organization the STS of organization
all shows that um you know
um chess is on the rise and I am I'm I'm
really happy to to state it okay and as
a chess player uh what do you think of
the of the chess so far uh two quick
draws uh and then two fighting games and
also maybe black doing very well so far
what what is your chess
opinion look um
I think it's again it's to be expected
the first draws two draws early draws um
like um uh heavyweight boxing you know
maneuvering just making sure that you
know you can just feel the opponent so I
I wouldn't be critical of both players
for that um uh then we saw a lot of
fight and uh and missed opportunities
and um yeah as a matter of fact black
missed chances in both games
um
I I wouldn't do something you know um
would make it as a system so black did
um well and and white was uh eventually
escaping um but
um probably there is the certain element
of U you know
um it's
like it's not by accident probably
because I think uh
um both place was white uh expect to
achieve something and it's not easy now
because opponents are well prepared and
uh they probably push a little bit too
too far so and then black had a chance
so Still Remains to be seen I I will be
very surprised if uh uh black eventually
the decisive games will be will be won
by black so I still think you know
um players with white pieces they they
may whoever would play wi will still
have an opportunity to to um demonstrate
that you know the advantage of a surf in
chess still counts right and four draws
at the start is said advantage to Magnus
or to fishy or not
not four draws are four draws it means
the score is equal 22 so and uh and I
I'm not sure that you know these
speculations they have any uh any ground
when you he after game one oh victory
for an game two victory for M no draw it
just means that the game is is is ended
with no result and there are certain
psychological advantages but this is not
a victory it's just it can disappear
next day so it's the
um I think that is if if longer the
match goes without result I think uh
it's probably VI will uh be gaining a
bit more confidence and actually because
Magnus might be might become more
nervous so uh but we're still talking
about minor things it's just it's it's
it's a psychological uh
background uh at the end of the day you
know still you have to win the match so
this
if it goes to the tie break that's 66 it
goes to
uh then again it's just we know both
players are great um rapid chess player
and or Blitz players but
um uh even if you look at the 66 it's
still just you know it uh potential
outcome 66 it could be whatever 12 draws
highly unlikely somebody wins somebody
loses or two wins two two two two losses
less likely but still possible
um and it depends you know what happens
so again is just psychological uh
background will be very important so is
the
um I think that 66 is likely but uh
still my view that eventually Magnus can
score uh one extra game and uh it's the
winning plus one is uh is likely for for
Magnus
okay I don't I I wasn't really planning
to go into the whole
feda Federation U treated with respect
or not is there anything you would like
to say or you would you just want to
skip this subject no I again I don't
think this subject is that important so
I just it's uh again it was a little bit
odd for me just to to to actually see
such arrogance
uh uh from from the feder from
the certain
officials um who were involved in the um
in the organization of this
match actually it is they I think they
even quickly recognize that it was wrong
and just next day they've changed the
attitude so which also probably know
it's a result of the massive uh
complaints on the on the internet on
Twitter or Facebook from the Indian
players and Indian public again I think
it's it's it's it's it worked out for
the advantage of the game of chess
because it showed that a lot of people
um are following the match and also it's
you know what make me feel very happy
and and uh and even excited that is many
Indian fans actually uh were
disappointed by by by this uh by the
lack of official uh uh um recognition of
my reval despite despite the fact that
they uh they knew that you know I was
rooting for magos I was on hiding it so
and uh and still the interest of Chess
uh uh prevailed in in their minds and I
again I think it's a very very good sign
so which shows that the chess in India
is on the rise not just because of
isanan who played phenomenal role of
course you know as the as a role model
and as a local hero but it's uh it's
it's it's a genuine interest and um
again it's a very good sign for
chess